[Musique]
alors après deux ans de lunettes noires
je ne sais pas ce qui m'a pris j'ai
décidé d'arrêter de faire de l'antenne
pas pourquoi ça m'énervait j'avais trop
le trac que je voulais plus enferrée
terre et j'ai inventé une émission qui
s'appelait télé zèbres leur télé z
c'était une chaîne en une heure donc il
y avait tout ce qui fait la télévision
mais en une heure alors pardon j'avais
la grande interview faite par yves
mourousi l'astrologie évidemment par
françoise hardy le détecteur de mensonge
fait par philippe manoeuvre et c'est là
que bolloc'h et solo se sont rencontrés
puisque bolloc'h animer un jeu et j'ai
demandé un arbitre et ses solos qui
monte sur le ring donc voilà c'est une
émission je n'apparaissais pas du tou
tes les zèbres a été arrêtée au bout de
trois mois par philippe guillôme quand
je dis mais pourquoi vous m'arrêtez
l'émission marche pas mal
c'était le samedi en access l'émission
marche pas mal
oui je sais je sais mais je vous arrête
parce que j'arrête l'émission de
frédéric mitterrand et l'émission de
claude sérillon donc j'arrête la vôtre
j'ai donc vous m'arrêtez par symétrie me
voilà je vous arrête par symétrie
heureusement ce gala s'est fait virer
deux mois après et à noël on a cherché
un nouveau président pour france
télévision hervé bourges que j'avais
connu sur tf1 qui nous aurait permis de
commencer arrive à la direction de
france télévisions et il dit la première
chose qu'il y ait dix mille faux faux
qu'ardisson reviennent c'est pas normal
il faut qu'il revienne tout de suite et
frédéric mitterrand aussi d'ailleurs
moi j'ai dit écoutez vous m'avez viré
j'ai pris un check je ne recommencerai
qu'en septembre et ce n'est pas con
parce que c'est la première fois où j'ai
eu six mois pour préparer une émission
j'ai préparé une émission qui s'appelle
double jeu alors double jeu c'était quoi
bas y avait des interviews bio je
racontais la vie des gens il y avait des
interviews formaté mais c'est là où j'ai
développé des interviews à concept un
peu plus spectaculaires comme lotto
interview c'est à dire on tournait
d'abord le mec qui posait des questions
et ensuite le même qui répondait donc
effectivement ça s'était très étonnant
pour l'époque même si c'était très
facile à faire
on a fait aussi star by star c'est à
dire deux stars qui s'auto interviews et
surtout l'interview confessionnal
j'avais fait installer dans un coin
du hall des folies bergères un vrai
confessionnal et à la fin de l'émission
vers 1h30 2h du matin je me retrouvais
dans le confessionnal avec l'invité
principal de l'émission
et c'est vrai que le fait d'être dans un
confessionnal faisait que l'invité me
disait des trucs qu'il aurait sans doute
pas dit ailleurs c'est très très bien
foutu on avait mis de l'écho on avait
des pas comme dans une église on avait
on entend des départs enfin voila on
était vraiment une ambiance d'église la
fin d'une émission complètement démente
double jeu c'est aussi l'arrivée de
laurent baffie
j'avais besoin de quelqu'un pour
m'écrire des bonsoir c'est à dire quand
je commence les missions m'écrire 2 3
vannes pour ce soit un peu drôle un peu
un peu sympathiques dont je convoque
baffie et je dis qu'est ce que tu fais
bien il lui dit je fais des magnétos
mais quoi comme magnéto d'aliments mon
train alors ils allaient dans la rue et
y voyait des gens qui avaient des
bouchons des petits blousons en skaï et
il disait aux gens mais ça vous dérange
pas quand même de savoir que on a abattu
des bd sky
pour faire votre blouson vous pensez à
la douleur de la maman sky
quand elle voit quand tu sembles chez
trouvé ça impeccable j'ai dit mais tu es
un génie
je t'engage tout de suite et on a fait
deux rubriques dans l'émission la
première c'était costard de stars alors
que star de star on se foutait des
invités je me souviens d'une émission
avec jean edern hallier grand
provocateur de l'époque et j'en ai dans
la vie on était allé demander dans la
rue à des gens ce qu'ils pensaient du
commandant cousteau
alors tout le monde disait évidemment le
commandant quoi briser cette formidable
aéro un type exceptionnel et on avait
fait croire jean edern hallier s'était
depuis longtemps par les jusqu'au moment
de la révélation il ya eu aussi la même
chose avec jacques martin lors on était
allés interviewer à la sortie des écoles
des adolescentes à qui demander de
raconter que lors de l'école des fans
jacques martin s'était pas très bien
comporté comme cela quand on a diffusé
sa jacques martin il s'est levé il
voulait partir il est parti dans la rue
d'ailleurs gelé poursuivi jeudi mais
enfin tu es content tu peux pas t'en
aller en face et comme en mai ce que
vous osez ferme vous rendez pas compte
et tout
ouais mais jacques tu comprends quand
même maintenant je comprends mais bon et
là il a eu cette phrase super il m'a dit
écoute
ok je vais te pardonne et embrasse moi
il m'a roulé une pelle ce qui était
quand même très marrant je trouve que ça
démontrait une certaine décontraction
dons qu'ils avaient co star de star il
est aussi le bas ficheux bas pichot et
là c'était des caméras cachées tout le
monde les connaît les fameuses caméras
cachées de la fille ont été faites
pendant la période de double jeu
évidemment il y avait aussi les sketches
un jour je dis je veux un éléphant rose
et c'était génial
il ya un semi remorque est arrivé devant
les folies bergère avec un éléphant
ils ont sorti les défend ils ont rentré
dans le hall des folies bergères il en
pas en rose qui sera interdite
aujourd'hui je vous le dis tout de suite
par les invalides et protection des
animaux
l'éléphant était tout rose et moi je
rentrais avec cortier la fille je
faisais je sais pas ce que j'ai en ce
moment je vois des éléphants roses et là
il y avait l'éléphant donc ça a duré
quinze secondes le plan sur les réformes
quand même et bah film disait moi c'est
marrant je vois des iguanes bleus on
n'avait pas dit guen bleus donc c'était
cette époque complètement dingue ou un
jour je fais un sketch soi-disant
bourges m'appeler parce que j'employais
des mots trop vulgaire sans doute et me
dit oui président oui président oui
président écoutez avait là je m'énerve
citi va comme ça ça fait 15 jours que tu
m'as pas touché d'accord c'est on
diffusera le lendemain de la leaf on est
convoqué avec vérifier huit ou neuf
heures du matin en fait très très tôt
surtout pour laurent on est convoqué
chez hervé bourges le patron et il
commence à nous sermonner et à mon fils
ira président vous avez fait un petit
rototo là et là j'ai dit ça y est on est
mort une autre carrière s'arrête
maintenant et et bourges a éclaté de
rire
et voilà heureusement dans ce hall des
folies bergère qui était vraiment le
summum du kitsch et du baroque
j'avais mis des lacs et des lacs et à la
française qui a porté à boire qui
s'occupait du public etc
j'avais dans le public des filles
habillées en marquise xviiie siècle
j'avais deux noirs qui tenait comme ça
hein
torch je me souviens qu'un jour c'est la
première fois que j'ai rigolé à la
télévision patrick timsit est invité il
y avait ces noirs avec des petits slips
comme ça ils commencent à soupeser pas
mal voilà ça serait impossible
aujourd'hui
et puis avait un jeu le jeu c'était info
ou intox
alors l'idée c'était de faire un sujet
du journal télévisé et puis de demander
aux gens s'ils étaient vraies c'était
faux il était très très bien fait et on
se laissait surprendre par exemple est
ce que stéphanie de monaco descendent
une lingère de constantine évidemment a
priori non sauf que dans les années 20
la famille grimaldi n'avait pas de
descendants et l'accord entre monaco et
la france c'est que s'il ya plus de
descendants monaco est rattachée à la
france donc il est quand même très
inquiet et on s'est souvenu qu'en prince
de monaco avait fait un enfant à une
lingère de constantine ils sont allés
chercher cette enfant et ils ont marié
avec un prince de polignac et la
dynastie des grimaldi est reparti alors
évidemment on invitait 7 et smaïn qui
est de constantine donc savoir quand
même qu'il avait une proximité avec
stéphanie de monaco s'est beaucoup
séduit
et puis on a été viré on a été viré par
la haute autorité de l'audiovisuel en
décembre donc le fait un an et demi même
pas un an et un trimestre et la dernière
émission
il avait des champs à moyens on était
tous assis sur nos chaises nos fauteuils
et les lacs et venez chercher le
mobilier est ce qui fait qu'à la sortie
on s'y retrouver tous assis par terre
c'était la fin de la dernière émission
ce que je vous recommanderais dans
double jeu j'ai reçu beaucoup de stars
américaines beaucoup de gens branchés
beaucoup de là c'est annie girardot
annie girardot s'est jamais autant
raconté que dans cette émission jeanne
mots pareils jeanne moreau qui parlait
de son père qui parlait de sa mère
qu'elle est danseuse aux folies bergère
oh c'était vraiment vraiment incroyable
que ces gens-là fasse des révélations
aussi aussi énorme
sacha distel que j'avais remplacé dans
ma première émission
enrico macias et là j'ai commencé à
faire un casting peut-être moins
branchés mais plus populaires et enrico
vient avec sa guitare il y avait
il y avait moi il y avait sa fille
questions publiques et quand il a fait
les premières notes
j'ai quitté mon pays tout le monde s'est
mis à pleurer lui mois et sa fille et je
me suis rendu compte en fait que je
faisais beaucoup de mariole à la télé je
me suis rendu compte que je pouvais être
moi même je pouvais rire quand timsit
faisait ses conneries je pouvait pleurer
quand enrico jouer son morceau et qui
suffisait d'être moi-même tels que
j'étais j'ai pas cessé de le faire après
je vous recommande aussi info ou intox
parce que les sujets sont vraiment bien
et puis tout ma fille même si vous
connaissez par coeur il ya des trucs
énormes
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous les mettez
un pouce bleus